Jeff Gerstmann I'm Peter Bryan we
usually do a section called ash to
reveal where we kind of get your ideas
about the games you've reviewed both of
you reviewed axiom verge for your
respective publications and that's
correct
Peter brand you enjoyed this game quite
a lot I love this game yeah would you
like to know why I would like to know
why you enjoyed this video okay well so
many of the games that have that has
sort of takes a lot of inspiration from
like Metroid Super Metroid even Bionic
Commando two-degree it sort of takes a
lot of elements from those games does
those like replicates but those games do
so well in a very good way and then just
adds all this crazy stuff on top of it
they're like way more weapons than you
need the world is super interesting and
the story just gets weirder and more
complex as it goes and you find that
like everything is building up and while
you're playing you just enjoy it more
and more and then you get to the end and
you're like dama I just want to keep
playing this game yeah and you realize
that there is reason to keep playing
this game and you know I'm I'm playing
again a second time right now just to
keep going yeah I'm not sure if I'm
gonna start another playthrough or
finish up the one I've got because I
have like 98% map and like 82% items or
something like that so it's like I might
just wait until now the games out there
people will probably just uncover the
last little bits over the next few days
here and then I go in and then do some
stuff there's some some some stuff that
I haven't done that you guys it seemed
like you and lark had found yeah those
are some crazy some crazy stuff in this
guy Locke conversant as well has been
speedrunning the crop that it isn't the
key he hadn't surgically just like
dissecting this thing that by day I mean
he knows everything but yeah this
speedrun right now is like 1 hour 45
minutes
oh he's gotten it even lower yeah it was
like 2 hours yesterday said yeah yes it
was 1:45 and then he's even like oh I
can show off about 20 minutes and the
Creator Tom happy
who's been working on this game for 5
years he told him that he couldn't beat
it in less than 3 oh really yeah that's
just cuz he loves all the content he
made in this game yeah you think he
wants to see doesn't he work for a
different we had him on the show I had
sugar live Patrick yeah it's like a side
project yeah I think he's like he was
part time at petroglyph right while this
was in development I'm not sure if he's
still there but
mmm that's my understanding yeah yeah it
is a really fascinating game it sets
itself up like you I mean obviously you
take a look at it you're like oh like
someone wanted to make a new Metroid
game whatever yeah is it just like it
always seemed to me like a like a real
homage kind of thing but is it more to
it than I think it really benefits from
that initial impression it even though
that I think will turn some people off
that are kind of sick of like the retro
style at this point it sets itself up
and you think like oh it's gonna to be
Metroid and you start expecting certain
types of power-ups and certain types of
weapons and certain type of game flow
you see areas where it's like oh well if
I could roll up into a ball I'd be able
to fit in there and it totally subverts
all of those expectations and the items
you actually get to do your traversal
and and kind of make your way through
the world are different and really
exciting and that for me was was one of
the the coolest surprises that it just
wasn't like some like love letter meant
to me boid
through and through like I personally
feel like it is in a way and I guess but
just say it did everything has a layer
on top of it that's original yeah so I
mean like for instance like you know
right when you start you run to the line
reticle gonna have to go like there are
some things that are like you know like
just carbon copies I feel like that that
is I think they you know that like
that's used really well sure to set up
the ways that it's not metroid but like
this address disrupter this crazy glitch
gun that you're just like yeah this is
the most interesting tool in the game in
my opinion this lets you transform every
enemy in the game and every enemy
responds to it differently for example
like this enemy turns into a little
platform that you can ride another one
an enemy turns into like this like you
know like cement chomping little thing
and it like starts eating away through
the environment in ways that you
couldn't so you're really incentivized
to use this thing on every enemy it also
works on the environment as well there's
a lot of stuff that you can transform
with that guy yeah it just quickly
becomes the sort of thing that you just
want to use everywhere every time you
get to an area where like I don't know
what to do next thing you know that
there are tools that you can use to try
to uncover secrets and every little nook
and cranny and and I found that just
really
warden yeah absolutely I probably
nineteen hours tomorrow I'm sure that
was my clock when I finished it but I
think I might've left it running for
idling with stuff like this beam you
know that that works on enemies and it
works on sort of glitchy areas that are
pretty visible but you guys they're also
you talked about all this stuff to
discover and all these secrets and you
know that sort of completion percentages
how like at the far end of the spectrum
the hidden stuff the stuff that you find
gratifying like rewards really close
inspection how esoteric how inaccessible
is that stuff I mean it's like full-on
fez deep like get on some kind of paper
out there like that kind of stuff
there's a little bit of that in here a
little bit of that like a lark did some
manual translation of a document in an
alien language use it yeah then you use
the Codex to get the English version of
that and then he translated that
language and then other places in the
world where you can't just apply a
filter he was able to devise what it
said like in a glyph like in a wall and
then you there's a password screen in
your menus he can put in passwords so by
deciphering the language he was able to
translate something in the environment
putting the password which then allowed
him to access an item so unless he
unless you sort of used that sort of
abstract thought like I can apply this
to that and I'll get something out of it
you might only see so much of the game
in its story there's still a lot there
and a lot of you a lot of stuff that's
easy to find that you're gonna feel
gratified but if you really want to dig
deep you can and gets even more
interesting yeah yeah there's there's
crazy stuff there the further down you
go but yeah I think it's still enjoyable
like at its base level you know yeah it
did so it's a good solid level of
difficulty it's about right it feels you
know it's like you die here and there
yeah but the the death penalty is very
slight and you know you can kind of keep
going and as somebody maybe who hasn't
played many Metroid games like I didn't
grow up playing that era of yes I was on
the Commodore stuff like it can you
enjoy this without needing all those
like references and nods and whatnot I
think so yeah I think you know like
it'll I think it'll hit the hardest for
people that have played those games like
I I don't have any real reference for
Metroid they're fine they're fine games
but but I'm not like crazy but some of
the things that people love about those
games right is like the discovery of new
tools and items
that allows you to go to new places that
before you saw and you were like man I
wonder what's there and then you get
something you're like I'm gonna go back
I'm gonna go do this thing that I wanted
to do like two hours the stuff that made
shadow complex really great something
that made like symphony of the night so
outstanding like this this has that same
stuff that little guy the guy that just
blew up there if you hack that thing and
starts spitting out health instead of
bugs it's you know there's there's just
a lot of really cool little things in
here
Aksum and this is all like really early
footage from the game yeah we didn't
want to spoil too much of the stuff that
you've lost cept you like just a minute
ago said the craziest thing that I've
seen in the whole I didn't say it was
consistent alright well that's a draw
this point is to a close there thanks
for watch come on Jeff yeah review upon
John Baum yep you guys give it five
stars yeah five out of five is a quick
look up as well it starts with the
beginning of the game and then at some
point I kind of give the warning and go
alright we're gonna load up a save this
ride it to show like all the traversal
stuff that's in there and all the
different tools so if people are kind of
on the fence and just wanna get spoiled
with that you can you can see that stuff
if you wanna perfect on your review went
up this morning as well no I would live
on Monday okay cool yeah give it eight
out of 10 I love the game I there are a
couple areas I felt like we're lacking
in attention the writing a little bit
for the main character he is very
unrealistic reactions is pretty common
and yeah you know I mean I think it's
his hair that kind of rubbed me the
wrong way but anyway ya know I love the
game I mean don't worry about the score
it's a it's a game you have to play
excellence it's available on PC
PlayStation 4 3 and justice ps4 or was
it run and then it'll come to Vita
relatively quickly he's working on it
right now I think the PC versions coming
out before Vita excellent alright so in
the contracts and weeks what is
thanks so much come on dude